monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues j'aurais
pu vous adresser monsieur le ministre ma
question par la poste mais il aurait
fallu que je prenne mon mal en patience
que je fasse le choix du thème revers et
son délai désormais de J + 3 ou alors
que je paie une lettre
ire une illette rouge que je devrais
scanner avant de l'importer sur un site
internet afin qu'un agent des postes
l'imprime et la transporte jusque chez
vous cet agent aurait même accès à ma
correspondance aussi confidentielle
soit-elle le timbre rouge n'est plus et
vous entendez faire passer cela comme
une lettre à la poste expression vouée à
la désuétude selon vous la mesure
effective depuis le 1er janvier est un
pas de plus vers la désagrégation du
service public qui doit assurer
l'égalité et l'équité et il n'y a pas de
plan B cette dématérialisation synonyme
de déshumanisation
ignore la fracture numérique qui
concerne selon l'Insee 13 millions de
Français vont-ils devenir des
sous-citoyens en conséquence vous lancez
dans 68 communes expérimentations de la
réduction de fréquences du passage du
facteur derrière la tournée du facteur
monsieur le ministre l'accueille à un
guichet ce sont des liens humains qui se
tissent bien souvent avec les plus
fragiles et les plus défavorisés or nous
savons que tout ce qui coupe les liens
sociaux abîment la démocratie si ce que
nous a dit à nouveau ce que nous dit à
nouveau cette mesure c'est que la
machine exclure tourne à plein régime
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
stopper cette opération de cases du
service public essentiel pour la
population quand le gouvernement va-t-il
entendre qu'un service public n'est pas
voué à être rentable
pour vous répondre la parole et
communiste délégué dans le char de la
transition et des télécommunications
monsieur barreau vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice variaz vous interroge le
gouvernement sur l'évolution de la
politique de courrier du groupe La Poste
à laquelle nous sommes très attentifs et
vigilant avec la première ministre de
l'économie et des finances et il ne nous
a pas échappé qu'effectivement les les
nouvelles les évoluent les évolutions
nouvelles ont suscité de la part de nos
concitoyens certaines questions et
inquiétudes légitimes permettez-moi de
vous rappeler les deux raisons pour
lesquelles la Poste fait évoluer
aujourd'hui son offre de courrier la
première c'est que les usages de nos
concitoyens ont évolué là où ils
envoyaient 45 lettres prioritaires en
2010 il n'en envoie que 5 en moyenne en
2021 ce qui ne veut évidemment pas dire
qu'il ne faut pas en envoyer et que par
ailleurs les évolutions prévues par le
groupe de la Poste permettrait selon les
calculs du groupe d'économiser 60 000
tonnes de CO2 par an soit 25% de la
consommation du groupe et par conséquent
grâce notamment à l'arrêt du transport
aérien dans l'Hexagone ceci étant dit si
vous voulez bien me laisser terminer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
quelques éléments qui je l'espère seront
de nature à vous rassurer d'abord les
timbres qui ont été les timbres rouges
qui ont été achetés avant la fin de
l'année sont évidemment fonctionnels
d'autre part la présence du facteur 6
jours sur 7 n'est pas remise en question
tout
usagé pourra se faire conduire au bureau
de poste à tout moment par un facteur
c'est un engagement du groupe La Poste
et enfin le la lettre service plus qui
arrive après deux jours et la lettre
verte qui arrive après trois jours
seront évidemment disponibles enfin
c'est l'histoire de l'expérimentation
que vous avez évoqué elle ne remet en
aucun cas en question la présence tous
les jours du facteur sur les territoires
et pour toutes les activités de
distribution de la poste je vous
remercie
monsieur Albi
tiens avec mon groupe c'est qu'après
l'hôpital le rail l'énergie la
disparition du timbre rouge monsieur le
ministre symbolise le démantèlement de
nos services publics patrimoine de ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas avec l'attaque contre
notre système de retraite c'est
l'ensemble du dispositif de solidarité
qui est mis en cause sous les injections
de Bruxelles l'exaspération des Français
est à son paroxysme en ce début d'année
allez-vous enfin les entendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]